[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
NOEILA FENANDEZ ARROYO:
Everyone please welcome Luvvie.
LUVVIE AJAYI: [INAUDIBLE].
NOEILA FENANDEZ ARROYO:
So good to see you.
Like, this is so, so great
that you see how much attention
you're [INAUDIBLE].
LUVVIE AJAYI: Oh, my God.
I was, like, [INAUDIBLE]?
NOEILA FENANDEZ ARROYO: Yes,
that's so hopefully, like,
after the conversation,
and hopefully, you
get the chance of
reading the book.
It's truly amazing.
You will follow this
woman even further.
You were telling me this is
the fourth or fifth office
you have--
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yes.
This is, like, my fourth
or fifth Google Office.
So now I'm, like,
I need to have,
like, a Google bucket list.
NOEILA FENANDEZ ARROYO: Yes!
LUVVIE AJAYI: And go
all over the world
and see how many Google
locations I can go to.
So I can eat all the snacks,
because that's what I do.
[LAUGHTER]
NOEILA FENANDEZ
ARROYO: So actually--
no, before we start
the conversation,
there is a sentence
that really caught me.
And that's more
from your TED Talk.
And it's a bit in connection
with what we just listened,
which is in a world that
wants us to whisper,
you choose to yell.
And you're not
saying that everyone
should be yelling,
necessarily, but definitely
we all have a big
role to play there.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yeah.
NOEILA FENANDEZ
ARROYO: And that's
very inspiring how you
intentionally said that's it.
I'm going to be speaking
loud about this.
What trigger?
LUVVIE AJAYI: What trigger?
Because I've just never been the
person to be quiet when I feel
cheated.
Ever since I was little, I
was the kid who even though--
whenever I got in trouble, I
got in trouble for my mouth.
I wasn't the kid that would get
in trouble for climbing trees
and, like, just
being disruptive.
I was being disruptive
with my mouth.
So if I felt like
somebody did or said
something that either took
advantage of me or cheated me,
I always had to say something
even if it got me in trouble.
So being Nigerian, we are very--
we revert to our elders.
So we are supposed to kind of
take the backseat to somebody
who's older than us.
I never believed in that mantra.
So it always got me in trouble.
So for example, if
somebody is older,
let's say, comes
up to you and says,
like, you should
give me your seat.
In Nigerian custom, you
would give up your seat.
Me, I'd be, like,
I was here first.
No!
So it's just this
thing where I've always
been compelled to
speak up whenever I
felt like something wasn't OK.
And it kind of followed
me through adulthood.
Now I'm always like, why don't
we point it out, or point out
something that's not OK?
Why are we constantly
quiet and allowing things
to happen that we don't like?
I am a huge fan of boundaries.
I think everybody needs to
operate with boundaries,
because it'll make life
easier for everybody,
as opposed to being
silently mad when
somebody crosses your boundaries
and you don't tell them.
So it's all part
of the same thing.
So I've always kind
of been this person.
And when we talk
about injustice,
I'm just, like, you know,
how do we find ourselves
in the place where we find
ourselves, where we look around
and we're, like,
things are not OK?
I always say it's because
well-meaning people are
being quiet.
We spend so much of
our lives just deep
sighing anytime things
are inconveniencing us,
as opposed to saying,
you know what?
I don't like that thing
that you just did.
I prefer you don't do it.
In that moment, it is
really uncomfortable, right?
Because you're, like,
I'm going to offend them.
But you just told
somebody something
that can allow them to
adjust their behavior.
Instead, we just
assume people know.
So I use the example of,
OK, who here gets tagged in,
like, random Facebook posts that
have nothing to do with you?
Who here actually likes it?
None of us, right?
So instead you're just, like,
oh, I hate when they do that.
And they keep it going.
And then it happens again, and
then you get irritated again.
What I do is, I literally will
message the person, no matter
if they are my friend, if
they're my uncle, my cousin.
I'd be, like, hey.
So listen, tagging
me to Facebook posts,
I don't like it.
Because then it
overruns my timeline.
I appreciate you.
I saw it.
But try not to do that.
And they'll be, like,
oh, you know what?
OK.
You're right.
I won't do it again.
They'll do it to
everybody else still.
[LAUGHTER]
But I won't be in there no more.
And I'm, like well,
I've said my piece.
So yeah.
I just think-- it just
makes life easier.
Because then everyone gets
to adjust their behavior
and then not annoy
each other so much.
NOEILA FENANDEZ
ARROYO: Absolutely.
So actually, what
you're just seeing here
is actually what you feel
when you're reading the book.
Because you're constantly in our
face with, like, very strong--
I mean, you're judging us.
LUVVIE AJAYI: And me.
NOEILA FENANDEZ
ARROYO: That's clear.
And you're judging
yourself through that.
But it's always with a
very strong sense of humor.
But you don't-- you're not
afraid of being very much--
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yeah.
I'm very straightforward.
When people say-- so I've
never necessarily thought
I was funny.
So when I read my own
writing, I rarely laugh.
Because I actually
mean what I just wrote.
I said it with a straight face.
So other people are laughing.
I'm, like, I actually meant it.
[LAUGHTER]
But I think humor is
really pointing out
the absurdities of the world.
I think comedy is actually
in just talking about what
is happening around you.
So my writing is funny to
people because it's just me
pointing out what's
ridiculous that we're seeing.
And I write like I speak.
So people who know
me in real life
will say I hear your voice
when I'm reading your book.
And I think that's the
ultimate compliment.
NOEILA FENANDEZ ARROYO: Totally.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Because
it means that no matter
what platform
you're seeing me on,
whether it is a TED Talk,
or my podcast, or my book,
or in person, it's always
going to be the same person
that you get.
NOEILA FENANDEZ ARROYO: Yeah.
I mean, it's interesting.
Because I have a toddler.
I think she's a monster,
even if he's very nice.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Toddlers
are absolutely monsters,
absolutely.
NOEILA FENANDEZ
ARROYO: I mean, doesn't
mean that you don't love
her, and that's she's funny.
But--
LUVVIE AJAYI: They are monsters.
NOEILA FENANDEZ ARROYO:
There's a monster part of her.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Absolutely.
Toddlers-- see here's the thing.
My theory is that toddlers
are supposed to be monsters,
because they're so cute.
You cannot have a
well-behaved cute child.
It's just too much.
That's too good.
I feel like it's like
an inverse relationship.
The cuter they are, the less
they know how to behave.
It is just life's balance.
NOEILA FENANDEZ
ARROYO: That's great.
So very interesting-- so you
published the book in 2016.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yes.
NOEILA FENANDEZ ARROYO: You
have said that at that time
it was, like, your
voice at your best.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Um--
NOEILA FENANDEZ ARROYO:
Would you say that, still--
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yeah.
NOEILA FENANDEZ ARROYO:
--after a few years?
LUVVIE AJAYI: I would say so.
I'm still very proud of
the book that I wrote.
I wrote my book 2015.
So May 2015 till October
2015, so five months--
and for almost four
years now, my book
is still as timely
as it was then.
And I set out to write
a book that was timely.
I wanted my book to be the book
where if somebody picked it up
in five, six years, it's
still relevant to their lives,
and it's still
relevant to the world.
And that is the
book that I wrote
and that's the book
I'm really proud of.
And what I'm seeing
lately is that there's
this resurgence of my book.
I don't know if people
are rediscovering it
because of my TED Talk.
But every day I get
tagged on Instagram.
And people would be, like, I'm
at my desk reading this book.
And I might get in
trouble, but I'm just
going to read here and
sit here and laugh.
So it's actually, yeah, it
is my voice at its best.
It is kind of my
manifesto, if anything.
So if you ever want
to know who I am,
read that book and it will
tell you exactly who I am.
NOEILA FENANDEZ ARROYO: But
it's very interesting, actually.
Because I'm Spanish.
Something that has happened
over the last couple of years
is the 8th of March has become
something very different
and actually has united
women across political views
or perspectives.
And it has become a movement.
We also had the Me Too movement.
So that there's
something in particular
that people is less afraid
of calling out things
that they're not
comfortable with.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Um.
NOEILA FENANDEZ ARROYO:
Do you see that?
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yeah.
And I think it comes with
us kind of peer pressuring
each other to do that.
So we peer pressure each
other to go to parties
and do random
things, and, like--
we do that all the time.
So I'm always,
like, why can't we
peer pressure ourselves and
each other to do better things?
So my whole thing is
my writing and the work
that I've been doing
for a long time is
I'm hoping that with me
being who I am, like, really
real in the way I talk and how
I show up in a room as myself
no matter what room I'm in, I'm
hoping that it shows somebody
else that you can do the same.
And I'm hoping that
with me speaking up
as this black girl who was born
in Nigeria, went to the US,
I know what it's like
to be marginalized.
And I still choose to speak up.
Even in spite of the
consequences that may come.
I'm hoping it really does
encourage somebody and give
them the words, the language,
and the courage to speak up.
I actually just got a
LinkedIn message last night
from somebody who said they are
taking a case at their office
to HR, because they
watched my TED Talk.
And it gave them the courage
to say, you know what?
I'm going to stand
up for myself.
And for me, those messages
are the best ones,
because it tells me
that I'm actively
making people step outside
their comfort zone--
strictly because I do that
for myself all the time.
So yeah, I do think it's
a moment for us to kind
of squad up in that way.
Speak up more.
And then back each
other up when we do it.
So I'm hoping more of
us have the courage
to start speaking up more.
Because I don't want
it to be extraordinary.
I don't want the
person who is telling
the truth in the
meeting all the time
and challenging people on the
bad campaigns and you know,
and saying, you know,
yeah, that person has said
this thing that was offensive.
I'm hoping that person who's
always stepping up on an island
by themselves, I'm hoping they
have partners next time they
step up.
I mean, so it's
no longer, here I
am about to challenge this thing
again because nobody else is
going to say anything.
I'm hoping that person
walks in the meeting
and says I'm going
to challenge this.
And I'm going to have backup,
because somebody else is
going to actually
speak up and say
I believe what they just said.
So that's the goal.
NOEILA FENANDEZ ARROYO:
So actually, it's
very nice to see the room.
It's very diverse.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yeah.
NOEILA FENANDEZ
ARROYO: And actually,
something that we're
trying to encourage people
more and more is, like, we
need allies in other fronts,
other perspective.
LUVVIE AJAYI: So I want to
challenge people to even
be beyond allies.
Allies are passive.
So allies are the people who
are, like, yeah, I understand,
and I see that that
thing is not OK.
That's an ally.
Cool, that's cute.
[LAUGHTER]
I think we're past the point
where allyship is useful.
Because a lot of people
will be, like, well,
I'm an ally because
I do think everyone
should have equal rights.
But then, OK, you think it.
What are you going
to do about it?
So that's where the
accomplice comes in.
We need more accomplices.
And those are
people who are going
to be active about their
beliefs and their thoughts.
So you're the person
who is, like, yes,
I saw that person be
disrespected in the meeting.
The allies saw it.
The accomplice walks up
to the person and says,
are you going to
make any action?
Do you need my backup?
That's the accomplice.
We need more accomplices.
Everyone is so comfortable
because you're, like, I'm
an ally.
And they're, like, yes.
Yay, me.
But if you are an ally and
you haven't done anything,
what are you an ally of?
You know, how have you made a
difference in a tangible way.
So it's a concept that I
learned from the protesters
of Ferguson, allies
versus accomplices.
Their whole thing
is we have to be
more accomplices and less ally.
NOEILA FENANDEZ
ARROYO: That's great.
Really appreciate.
So another metaphor that
you use that I think
helps very much, you talk
about the domino effect,
that people don't have to be
at the front of the rights
movement.
But it can be a little act
that can cause that effect.
Can you can you talk
to us a little bit
about that perspective?
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yes.
It's just the idea
of a domino, when
you hit one and all of
sudden the rest of them fall.
Life kind of operates
the same way.
There usually has to
be one person that
makes a move, really, one
catalyst who will then allow
everybody else to follow them.
But here's the thing is
we're always afraid to one,
be the catalyst.
Because it is scary.
Because it probably means you're
putting yourself out there.
It probably means you're
stepping outside your comfort
zone.
It probably means you're going
to do something scary, right?
And we're always waiting
for that one other person
to do it first, as opposed to
taking it upon ourselves to be
that person.
So if everybody's waiting
for the one person,
who's going to be
that one person?
So I'm always, like,
well, somebody in the room
has to choose and
make the decision,
because it is a decision,
to be the first one, to be
the domino who will then allow
everybody else to follow them.
For the MeToo movement,
it was to Tarana Burke.
She started the MeToo
organization 12 years ago.
So when it became a hashtag
and everyone was, like, MeToo,
she was, like, oh.
She was a catalyst.
So if we don't have catalysts,
then how do movements happen?
Because then we
think about movements
in terms of these grand
gestures, the Civil Rights
movement, and all
these big things.
So it feels too big for
us as regular people.
We're just, like, I
can't be that person.
And I always say,
take the pressure off.
It's not necessarily
about starting a movement.
It's about doing one thing.
And that one thing could
end up spreading wildly,
but it might not.
But at least, just
do that one thing.
Start somewhere.
So it's, like, a tweet.
You tweet something,
one person might see it
or zero people might see it.
Or 30,000 people might see it.
100,000 people might see it.
You never know.
By just doing the thing
that you're compelled to do
and not letting the
fear of consequence
always stop you--
because I always
let people know that
I know in a room
where I'm sitting in
front of the room,
I am in a position of
power and privilege,
even if I sit in a
room as a black girl.
And in those moments,
my job is to disrupt
what's happening
because I have the mic.
Right?
So we usually
think of ourselves,
sometimes we think of ourselves
as what we are marginalized in.
We think of ourselves
as less powerful
than we are, just
because we're, like, I'm
a woman in an industry
that is full of men.
Well, are you the VP
of the department?
You are powerful then.
You are way more powerful
than certain men in that room.
Use that power in a way that's
going to push something forward
and yeah, make the room
that you're in better.
NOEILA FENANDEZ
ARROYO: That's awesome.
So you say black girl.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yes.
NOEILA FENANDEZ ARROYO:
That's actually a theme
that we talk a lot about it.
I was talking with Jacqueline
that runs the black [INAUDIBLE]
organization here in Dublin.
And she tells me that
more and more you see
how these themes interconnect.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yeah.
NOEILA FENANDEZ ARROYO: It's,
like, when is the glass ceiling
and when is the [? iron ?] cast?
How do you choose?
Do you choose something to
battle as a woman, or something
to battle as a black
person, or actually,
because we're
seeing more and more
that actually
everything is much more
complex and interconnected.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yeah.
Everything is definitely
more complex, interconnected.
As a black woman,
I'm seen as black
first before a
woman often, right?
So when we talk about diversity,
when we talk about power, when
we talk about access,
the black usually
will come first, because people
see that in a different way
as they see white women.
Right?
So a white woman is
seen as woman first,
not white first, woman.
So that means our
issues are different,
and they're multilayered.
And the things that we hit
against are also different.
So as a black woman, not only
am I dealing with the womanhood
and having to make sure I am
not too assertive in a room
so people don't think I'm
bossy, which I don't care about,
then I have to deal
with the black.
Which if you are too
confident, or if you speak up
without emojis in
your tones, people
think you're too aggressive,
which I also don't care about.
But I have the privilege
to not care about it
because I work for myself.
And I move in spaces
where I don't have bosses.
And I understand that people
who are in the offices
are constantly having
to deal with this.
Be clear that the black
woman who is your co-worker
is constantly checking her email
over and over again before she
presses send because she's
afraid that somebody's
going to go to HR and
say she's too short
because she didn't put an
extra please or a compliment
sandwich.
You know the
compliment sandwich.
You want to ask
somebody for a report,
and you need it by 5:00 PM.
So you have to be, like,
oh, my God, hey, girl, I
love your hair.
You're looking bomb today.
Can I get this report by 5:00?
Your shoes are fire.
Thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
You've got to send this
email with all these niceties
and then you put your
ask in the middle,
so people don't
feel-- because if you
send an email that's, like,
hey, I need this report by 5:00.
Thanks.
Oh, my God.
Why is she so sharp
to me in email?
You're, like, I was on
the go sending this email.
I just sent what I needed.
You added tone to it--
tone that wasn't there.
And people have to constantly
do this in corporate.
And because you have
to do your actual job
and then massage people's
egos as your second job,
that is exhausting.
And oftentimes, when I talk to
people of color in corporate,
this is a huge
issue, huge issue,
where they're, like, I
can't show up as myself.
Because every single
day, I have to play
the role of nonthreatening
black person to my co-worker who
sees me and automatically sees
tone in what I just sent them
when there was no tone.
So it's one thing
that I always--
I need people to get out
their feelings in business.
If your co-worker sends
you a one sentence
email that's, like, hey, I
need this thing at 5:00 PM.
Where's the tone?
Where did you find that tone?
And this happens all the time.
People go to HR.
I know people who work
in HR who are, like,
yeah, no, the reports I get
are absolutely ridiculous.
Adults are really sensitive.
They'll be, like, oh, my God.
She was just really short to me.
Why was she short me with me?
Well, she sends
these emails, right,
where she just asks for stuff?
[LAUGHTER]
And you're like, what
was she supposed to do?
Write you a tome and a
poem and then [INAUDIBLE]??
So I need adults to
get out their feelings.
I need people to do
business properly.
And I need people understand
that there's unconscious
bias that they carry.
Right?
The girl who walks in the office
who is not a morning person,
who's, like, I can't talk
to nobody before 11 o'clock.
I'm that person.
I can't deal with people
before 11 o'clock.
So I know I wouldn't
do well in corporate.
You all would just
think I'm rude.
[LAUGHTER]
I would be written up
by HR a couple of times.
So they'd be, like, she
doesn't talk before noon.
Guys, I don't drink
coffee, either.
So listen.
I need to get my
energy naturally.
So give me some hours.
But I need people to understand
that unconscious bias is
a huge part of our lives.
How we walk in a room and the
things that we automatically
expect of people and how we
project things on people--
we're constantly projecting
our own issues on other folks.
So we're, like, well, this
person was mean to me,
or this person was short to me.
I had somebody who told
me because I told her
that the work that she
did, I didn't love it,
I was demeaning her.
Demean by saying,
hey, like, I actually
think you should fix that,
because there's this error.
This person sees
that as demeaning.
Now think about that.
It's two things.
There's always two
stories, right?
There's always one person
who's, like, well, I'm not sure
what I did that was wrong.
There's always one person
who's deeply offended.
And there's actually
what probably
happened in the middle.
Yes, maybe I could
have been nicer.
But I doubt the word
demean and attack.
That's another
thing that happens
in corporate and in offices
and just in general.
Black women get accused
of bullying co-workers.
People use the word attack
and bully against us
very often, as opposed to being,
like, we had an interaction
that didn't feel friendly.
Or it maybe felt short.
People would actually
be, like, I felt bullied.
And I'm, like, whoa.
How did we get there?
It's subconscious bias.
And we walk with it every day.
We carry these chips
on our shoulders.
And we sometimes think we are
allies to the point we're,
like, oh, we're so good.
But a lot of well-meaning people
do racist and prejudiced things
to co-workers, to
friends, friends, right?
So people they approach
every single day.
And then when they're
challenged about it,
they instantly feel
attacked and bullied.
Right?
Because when you are not used
to being checked all your life,
any type of challenge will
come across as an attack.
And it's something that
people deal with all the time.
And I always wonder if
people are aware that this
happens right under their nose.
NOEILA FENANDEZ ARROYO: So I
mean what you say is, like,
it's--
I wanted to bring
out to be something
like we are in Google.
I was sharing with Luvvie,
like, I'm a bit more
than a year in the company.
And something that I thought
we were in a better place--
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yeah.
NOEILA FENANDEZ
ARROYO: --it's actually
like how we are creating that
same sense of opportunity
for every single
one, independently
of what's your background,
what's your race.
And actually, even we think we
have created that environment,
we have a lot of issues.
And those issues are
not only in the US.
They are also here
in Dublin, which
is a pretty significant
multicultural--
LUVVIE AJAYI: It's
a global thing.
It's a universal thing.
I think people always think that
they're better than they are.
We really do.
And that is real.
Because you will find that out
when you challenge somebody.
That is really when you find
out if somebody is an ally, when
you challenge them.
Because you feel like
an ally when you always
get along with this person.
But when a moment of conflict,
you instantly switch,
that person is not an ally.
When people are challenged,
they show who they really are.
And I find that, as
a woman, as somebody
who's challenged men
in certain spaces,
and the response I've
gotten has been fascinating.
So I'll tell you the story that
I told shortly in my TED Talk
about being asked to speak
at a conference in Amsterdam,
Europe--
I can't remember where.
I think it was Amsterdam.
Yeah.
It was a tech conference.
And they came to me,
sent me an email.
Said we'd love for
you to come, speak.
And I was, like, great.
So I sent it to my manager.
My manager passes
it back to them,
gives them my fee,
talks about what's
required to have me in a room.
And they replied back and
said, well, we don't really
pay speakers.
So we would give
Luvvie exposure.
And I was, like,
well, I'm exposed,
because you came to me.
So clearly--
[LAUGHTER]
--I'm already very exposed.
So I'm good on that.
Thank you.
So I was, like,
this is interesting.
So I went-- I'm part of this
thing called The List, which
is a list of 250 dope women in
business and media and tech.
And we talk.
We tell each other stuff.
We talk numbers, which is the
stuff that nobody ever does,
right?
We talk about resources.
So I would go on The List,
and I was, like, hey,
I was asked to speak
at this conference.
They say they
don't pay speakers.
Is that true?
Is that a blanket policy?
South by Southwest
doesn't pay any speakers.
TED doesn't pay any
speakers, across the board,
no matter who you are--
so yeah, fair.
So in 15 minutes.
I've got about 10 answers
of people being, like, oh, I
spoke there last year.
They definitely
paid my way there.
Oh, I spoke there and
they bought my books.
Oh, my guy spoke there
and they paid his way
and bought his books
and paid his travel.
So I end up collecting
all this information.
And I realized
that the hierarchy
was white men were paid to
speak at this conference.
White women their
travel got paid for,
so they at least had that.
And then black women were
asked to pay their way
to speak there.
That was a clear pattern.
So I was, like, oh, I
got to talk about this,
because this is a problem.
[LAUGHTER]
So I told my agent.
So I was, like, I'm just
giving you a heads up.
And I told my
manager, who is here.
And I was, like, all right.
I want to talk about
this on a larger
scale, because I don't think
what's happening here is fair.
And I'm not going
to talk about--
I'm not even going to say the
name of the conference, right?
I'm going to give them
the pleasure of that.
My manager's-- well, my
manager, she knows me.
She knows I ain't got no chill.
My agents-- my agents
were, like, oh, my gosh.
If you do this, this is risky.
Because what if other
conferences see this and are,
like, hey, she's a troublemaker.
We shouldn't hire her.
I was, like, I am
a troublemaker.
But you all should hire me.
But I was, like,
I have to do this,
because in the position of power
that I'm in as a speaker who's
been at it for over
eight years, who's
been on some grand stages,
who gets 50 speaking
engagements every year,
I can put some speaking
engagements on the line here.
I can put some
money on the line.
And because if I can't do that,
who am I expecting to do it?
Is it the person who
just started last week?
Is it the person who's
never done a major talk?
No.
So I'm going to say this.
So I go on Twitter
and I was, like,
so there's this
conference that makes
15 million euros a
year that wants me
to pay my way to speak there.
And this is not OK,
because I find out
this pattern about payment,
this pay inequality.
Yo, it went crazy.
People on Twitter were,
like, oh, my gosh.
That's happened to me, too.
And then people also
figured out the conference,
because I also did not
not give them clues.
[LAUGHTER]
So people were, like,
oh, is it the Next Web?
I was, like, yes!
[LAUGHTER]
No chill-- so in The List
is a "Forbes" reporter.
And she hit me up.
She was, like, I'm
seeing this thread.
She said, would
you actually want
to go on record to
talk about this?
Because I want to
write a piece about it.
And I was, like, yeah,
I would go on record.
She's, like, OK.
And then she hit
up Gary Vaynerchuk,
because he had keynote
at the conference.
And Gary decided to go
on record, too, and be,
like, yeah, no, they paid me.
Yeah, he backed me up.
He was, like, no, no, I
definitely got compensated.
So she wrote this
piece in "Forbes."
Oh my, gosh.
And the picture on
the "Forbes" piece
is my last Google
talk at Menlo Park.
So it was, like,
Luvvie at Google.
Hey, they don't want to pay her.
[LAUGHTER]
So when the piece came
out, the piece goes nuts.
The dude who runs
the Next Web sees it.
European guy, doubt
he's used to being
challenged by a black
girl or anybody, really.
So he sends me and the
"Forbes" write up an email,
where it was three paragraphs of
straight dog whistle language,
right?
He was, like, well,
you know, yeah, I mean,
we do pay some speakers.
We choose to pay,
I mean, the ones
who we feel have the
value in our market.
Maybe if Luvvie was--
maybe if this was a
more urban market,
Luvvie could command her fee.
He literally put maybe if
this was a more urban market.
So let me get this straight.
You're asking me to come.
And then you say
because it's not urban,
because apparently white
people don't understand me,
because you know, I must be
speaking a different language--
and it was great, because in
that moment he proved my point.
He actually proved my point.
It was so good that the
"Forbes" writer copied the email
and added it to the piece.
[APPLAUSE]
NOEILA FENANDEZ
ARROYO: That's awesome.
[LAUGHTER]
LUVVIE AJAYI: And
a couple of people
actually pulled out from
speaking at it that year.
I don't know what else is
going on with the Next Web,
but in those moments,
I think about that guy.
You know what I mean?
Like, who got challenged in this
way, and bulked up in defense,
as opposed to being,
like, you're right!
And the fact that he basically
helped prove my point
was sweet.
Because we don't get
these opportunities often.
And I was, like, yes.
And that is the year
that I did my TED Talk,
three months later.
NOEILA FENANDEZ
ARROYO: There you go.
LUVVIE AJAYI: And
I think about--
and I use that as an
example for people
whenever they're
afraid of speaking up.
Because I did put some
money on the line.
I was afraid.
I was, like, OK, let me see.
OK, if I don't get any
more speaking engagements,
I guess I'm going to have to
write my second book for real.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm going to have to figure
out a different business model.
But I knew that it was risky.
Because, yes, somebody could
see me and be, like, oh, my God.
If we invite Luvvie to
come, is she going to--
I don't make a
habit out of talking
about how people mistreat me in
that way publicly in business.
I don't.
And every week, she's,
like, oh, and then
this person asked me--
because I don't do that.
So this was an
extraordinary moment.
And I'm, like, again,
we have to ask ourselves
what we are afraid of.
If the worst thing that
was going to come from that
was that I would get less
speaking engagements,
is that worth me
shutting up and letting
this conference continue to
do pay inequality things?
Is it worth me also
not showing and not
putting my name on
the line in the way
that I'm telling other people
to put their names on the line?
Sometimes the means
justifies the end.
And I just know how it
encouraged other people
to speak up.
And oftentimes, the thing
that we're afraid of,
that consequence doesn't come.
I didn't get fewer
speaking engagements.
I actually got more as a result
of speaking up in "Forbes."
So yeah, do it.
Say it.
And then let the chips fall.
Just always ask yourself what
is the worst that could happen?
OK.
If it happened, so what?
Do you die?
No.
You'll be OK.
Figure out something else.
OK.
If you go speak up at HR
because something awful happened
at work, or you saw something
awful happen to your co-worker
and you happen to
get demoted for it,
does that mean you
can't get a new job?
Truly, does it mean you
will be fired today,
can't ever get a new job,
and will end up homeless?
Is that the case?
OK.
No.
Great.
Then why are you being quiet?
Because you're afraid
of a bad review?
OK.
So what is the worst
that can happen?
You speak up in a
meeting about something
that's not OK, what is
the worst that can happen?
OK.
Maybe your co-worker
who was your--
actually, maybe
your manager then
makes your life a
living hell because they
give you terrible
assignments or make
you stay at work for longer.
OK.
If your work environment
gets terrible,
can you not get a new job?
Truly, we are always
afraid of the consequence.
But we don't really
think about, OK,
if that worst thing that you
are afraid of does happen,
does it end your life?
Does it end your career?
Does it actually
end your ability
to feed yourself and
clothe yourself and put
a roof over your head?
If the answer is no, then
you've got to say this thing.
I feel like we pass
the buck too often.
Somebody else, oh,
that person will do it.
I don't have to do it.
But everybody's thinking
I ain't got to do it,
so nobody does it.
And then you figure
out, oh, nobody did it.
That's how nobody did it.
Everybody passed the buck.
NOEILA FENANDEZ ARROYO: Awesome.
So we should get some
questions from the crowd.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Ask me anything.
NOEILA FENANDEZ ARROYO:
Some questions--
who wants to be the first?
Who wants to be the domino?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: First of
all, I loved the talk.
And I love your attitude.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Just something of a
question that comes to my head.
Sometimes, even when you
were talking about the MeToo
movement, a lot of times--
this is even when
someone wants to speak up
and is aware of all of
these consequences--
sometimes this thought
comes to mind that--
am I being too, you
know, sensitive?
Or is it something that
was just probably said
in a joke, or am I being--
you start to go on that
route of self-doubt.
That am I being
too oversensitive?
Or is it really an issue?
And sometimes when
that happens, right,
even in the MeToo
movement, like,
I'm just taking an example
of the MeToo movement.
Because after that
I realized I would,
like, especially from guys
and some girls, as well,
there were jokes coming.
That you know, oh, now
she's going to say MeToo.
So do you see that, you know?
Where is that line?
And how do you get
rid of that self-doubt
that, hey, I am raising my
voice about the right thing.
LUVVIE AJAYI: The thing
is that we've been told,
we've been too everything
for a long time--
too sensitive, too much,
too loud, too bossy,
too assertive, right?
So we've erred on the
other side in order
to make sure we're not too.
You will always be
too to somebody.
No matter who you are.
You will always be too much, too
loud, too quiet, too sensitive,
to somebody.
In those moments, honestly,
just do a gut check.
How am I feeling right now?
Does this actually feel like
something that is not OK?
That is the only
question to ask yourself.
If the answer is yes,
it does not feel OK.
Don't ask yourself 15 questions.
Because you will always talk
yourself out of those moments.
You will always talk
yourself out of speaking out.
Because you'll be
like, you know what?
I'm not going to be
any type of trouble
because I don't want
to be too something.
Listen.
Get used to being too something.
[LAUGHTER]
You will always be too
something to somebody.
There are moments where you can
even make yourself more quiet,
and even somebody will
still find you too loud.
And you know what?
Next time I need to
give you something
to make you feel like I was
too loud, for real, for real.
[LAUGHTER]
So I mean, I have to
say you have to do a gut
check with yourself.
And just figure out
did that feel good?
That is really the question.
Did it feel good?
If it did not feel good,
then that joke was not OK.
And also, if the
joke is making me
feel like less than a
person, or if the joke makes
me feel like my voice does not
matter, that's a terrible joke.
If the joke makes me
feel like I'm not safe,
that's a terrible joke.
So whoever is making
it, a boy or a girl,
that's a terrible joke.
And here's the thing.
Here's a key you
can use if somebody
says a joke in your midst
that is inappropriate,
that makes you
feel uncomfortable.
Where you're, like, I
want to say something.
I don't know what to say.
Ask him a question.
So say they make this joke.
And they're, like, ha, right?
You should be, like,
I don't get it.
Explain that.
What does that mean?
[LAUGHTER]
Literally, just ask
them the question.
Because then, in that
moment, they actually
have to explain
that joke to you.
And if it's a
racist, homophobic--
just any joke that
is not appropriate,
that person in that moment
is now put on the spot.
Explain that.
What does that mean?
I don't get it.
And then they'll have to
be, like, you know how.
I know how what?
[LAUGHTER]
No.
Ask questions.
In fact, if you want
to challenge something
that happens in a
room, and you don't
want to just say the words,
that's not OK, ask questions.
So ask the person, so
tell me more about that.
Because you've made them, in
that moment, sit in that thing
that they just did, and then
further dig deeper into it.
And even they will be like hm.
If they don't want to
explain the joke to you,
then even they know the
joke is not appropriate.
So then you got
them in a corner.
Just ask them questions.
Just be the person
that's, like, really?
Tell me more.
NOEILA FENANDEZ
ARROYO: That's awesome.
LUVVIE AJAYI: And it's
a great tool to use.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I'm definitely going
to use the question.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Hey.
Ask questions.
AUDIENCE: So thank you very
much for sharing your conference
experience.
As you were speaking
about it and you mentioned
tech conference in
Amsterdam, I immediately
thought it's the Next Web.
LUVVIE AJAYI: See?
AUDIENCE: It's crazy.
So I've been an attendee.
In 2015, I was still a student.
And I also had a very
misogynistic experience
overall as an attendee.
And I wrote a Medium
article about it.
And it also got quite
a bit of traction.
It was also shared on
Twitter quite a bit.
And it also got to the
founder of the conference, who
also gave a very lame,
blah, blah, type of reply.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Of course.
This is a habit.
AUDIENCE: So I feel,
like, it's crazy
that that happens at every
single level of that conference
from attendee all
the way to speaker.
LUVVIE AJAYI: I
love this, though.
Because the existence
of your article
and the existence of mine
corroborate each other.
And that instantly gives
this story more credibility.
Even if you were doubting what
I just said, somebody else just
essentially just verified it.
And think about that same
type of thing in a room.
I want us to operate like
that every single day.
Where you're seeing
something, you
believe something
somebody else just said,
and you think your voice
is not needed in it.
Your voice is absolutely needed.
Because you end up
being somebody's backup.
There's power in numbers.
You and I saying the same thing
right now, it's hard to be,
like, both of y'all lying!
[LAUGHTER]
It's super hard to--
somebody has to be, like, mm,
I don't believe it.
Sure.
You can maybe not believe me.
Or maybe you don't believe her.
But then we put our
stories together,
and it's, like, now it's harder
for me not to believe you.
So in a room, when
you are the person
who is always speaking up,
I hope you have that person.
And if you are not the person
who is always speaking up,
please back up
the person who is.
Here is my suggestion.
When you are going
into meetings,
you should have a pre-meeting
with your allies--
[LAUGHTER]
--dead ass.
Have a pre-meeting where
you're, like, OK, we're
about to go into this
meeting about this campaign
that we already know is
kind of going to be tough.
Right?
Have a pre-meeting with the
other person who you know
agrees with you.
And be, like, hey,
so in this meeting,
here's what I'm going to say.
If I'm going to point out that
this campaign that we want
to do is not a great
idea because it
has misogynistic undertones,
it's kind of racist,
it's kind of Islamophobic,
or whatever it is,
whatever the reason, I
have a problem with it.
Do you see where
I'm coming from?
The other person
goes, I actually do.
Because you know, you see
somebody in a meeting,
when they're deeply
uncomfortable across the table
from you, and y'all both
making eyes like eh.
[LAUGHTER]
But you're not saying nothing.
Talk to that person afterwards.
And then in the
pre-meeting, you're,
like, I saw you in the meeting.
You weren't digging it.
I wasn't either.
Great.
OK.
So in this meeting, I'm
going to bring this up.
Can you back me up?
I got you.
You instantly walk into the
meeting with more confidence
because you know
you're not going
to be on the island by yourself
when you finally do speak up.
You already know you
have built-in backup.
And that built-in backup
makes your voice stronger,
because two of you
can't be ignored.
One of you, maybe, one of
you can maybe be silenced.
Two of you can't, really.
And then, if you
get a third person?
Oh, oh, come on.
If you get a third
or fourth person,
you're in that meeting winning.
So if a third person
is, like, yeah,
I actually do agree with them.
I don't think this
is a sensitive--
NOEILA FENANDEZ
ARROYO: That's it.
LUVVIE AJAYI: --story that tells
something that we want to say,
literally the person who
is heading the meeting,
who is insisting
this campaign is
going to happen because they
think is the best idea ever,
now has to listen.
Because as a leader, you can't
ignore three people telling you
the same thing in
the same moment.
Because even if you
want to ignore it,
everybody else is watching.
Get your pre-meetings
together, right?
Walk into the meeting
with the whole wolf pack.
Because in the wolf pack,
nobody beats the wolf pack.
They can beat you,
maybe, as an individual.
The wolf pack, though--
you come in there squadded up,
and you're, like, we're ready.
We're going to do this.
And then everybody walks
out the room better for it,
because you probably
just stopped
something disastrous
from happening,
which is what I always
think about whenever
brands do awful campaigns.
Like the Pepsi stuff
and the Dove stuff--
I'm always, like,
there was somebody
in that room who knew this
was not going to go well
who was too afraid or
not empowered enough
to speak up about it.
There were absolutely--
guarantee you-- there's
somebody along the
way, who was probably
like this shouldn't
happen like this.
But they either lived
in a working environment
where being challenged gets
you punished, which is awful,
and that comes from
leadership down--
if leadership has
created an environment
where they are untouchable,
can't be challenged.
If you listened to
the Theranos doc,
you'll see that thing is real.
People will end up just
not doing their best work
because you never grow
from being challenged.
Either that, or this person
who is sitting in the room
was just like, this
is not my business.
This is not my charge.
So I'm not going to
speak up about it.
Or this person was,
like, you know what?
I'm usually the one
speaking up all the time
being on the island by myself.
Today I'm going to take a
break and see what happens.
I'm going to let him have it.
I know this is going
to be disastrous.
I'm just going to be quiet.
Because I'm tired of being the
one that's always speaking up.
And on that day, when the
campaign is checked off
and it goes out, and people
lose their minds on social,
because of course, it's
a terrible landing,
I'm always, like,
there was definitely--
this is a failure of leadership
beyond just the leader
not seeing it.
It means the leader has been
breeding an environment where
they can't be challenged.
And that person who
went to speak up
did not feel like
they had the place.
I'm telling you, if
you have a company that
encourages challenging, you
will do the best work possible.
Because in every
room, if people know
they are going to call
you out on your bullshit,
you will show up
in that room better
than you were going
to show up before.
Because you'll be like, hm, if
I don't show up well, if this
is not going to be a
great idea, somebody
is going to call me out on it.
And I don't want
to be called out.
So I'm going to make sure when I
step in this room this idea has
been thought through.
I have figured out
all the blind spots.
I have figured out how
to make it already good
so nobody in that room has
cause to challenge me on it.
It will make you
step up your game.
I know it makes me
step up my game,
because I surround myself
with people who challenge me.
Like, my friends tell me
I'm useless all the time.
It's great.
It keeps me going.
Right?
Because I know that
anything I bring
to them, if it is not correct,
they will call me out on it.
Which means if I'm
bringing it to you,
it's going to be correct.
Because I don't want you
to call me out on it.
So then I come up better.
I show up to you better.
I'm not bringing trash to
you, because I've already
realized if it's trash,
you're going to throw it out.
If I'm allowed to
bring whatever to you,
I'd be bringing
all types of stuff.
And you'd be, like,
who has time for this?
You didn't think this through.
Why are you wasting my time?
It just makes everybody's
life better, easier,
and you will do better work.
NOEILA FENANDEZ ARROYO: Awesome.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about the fact
that you said that we
usually think that we are
better than we actually are.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Mhm.
AUDIENCE: And if you are
in that kind of space,
and you feel like this
isn't happening to me,
but I know it's happening,
I see in the numbers
that we are not 100% inclusive,
what would be your advice
to spot those things
and take action,
although it's not visible,
or it's not super clear
what that is?
LUVVIE AJAYI: Just
talking about it--
you know, if it's
not super clear
that this thing is
happening, but you
feel this under tension,
this undercurrent,
start having a
conversation about it.
Just being like, I know--
I've been feeling this thing.
I don't if anybody else has
been feeling this thing.
Am I tripping?
Am I just thinking
too hard about it?
Even just, yeah, even
the whole too sensitive--
just have the conversation.
Here's how I'm feeling.
Am I being too
sensitive about it?
Is there something else that
I should be looking out for?
What can we do?
Because I feel this
undercurrent of tension.
I think in the moments
that we are not sure,
use your words to
say you're not sure.
You can even say, I
don't know what to do,
but I see there's
something wrong here.
That is actually an action, as
opposed to being quiet, trying
to figure it out in your
head, and then just not saying
anything.
I say your lack of
being sure is OK.
You don't always
have to be sure.
But I think you can
talk it through.
Because somebody else
is probably feeling
unsure, too, about
the same thing.
And you can work it through.
I think transparency is huge.
Vulnerability is huge.
In the moments when we don't
know, being able to say,
I don't know.
We also live in a society
that wants us to always know.
Like, everything
is figure outable.
If you don't know, Google it.
[LAUGHTER]
But there are some
things you can't Google.
You can't Google your feelings.
You can't Google certain
things that haven't happened.
You can't Google the
undercurrent, right?
So be able to say to
somebody, you know what?
There's this thing happening.
I'm not sure about it,
but it doesn't feel right.
It's OK.
I don't know when--
I don't know how we're
expected to do business
properly when one, we're not
expected to make mistakes.
And then we're also not expected
to admit when we're not sure.
We're always supposed to know.
So figure it out!
No, you didn't know,
say you don't know.
I think talk it through.
But again, I think it might even
take spaces like this, right?
Where maybe once a
month-- and I think
Google has this program in other
places, but just in general,
it helps to just have a
space where you can be, like,
let's just talk freely.
What's up?
How are you feeling?
How's the environment?
Do you feel empowered
to speak up?
You know, you may be able to, in
the room with 40 other people,
be able to say I can't
really put my finger on it.
But things don't feel right.
And then other people
can be, like, yeah,
there's this weird tension that
I started noticing after this.
Talk it through as a company.
Talk it through as a
department, as a team.
But again, it has to
be the environment that
has fostered that, right?
So hopefully it
becomes the environment
that then fosters that.
I think companies like
Google are at least trying.
We'll fall short.
That's to be expected.
It's not going to be all of a
sudden everybody's kum ba yah.
But the attempt is
at least necessary.
AUDIENCE: Great.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Thank you, actually, for
just talking about this.
Because that actually
answers part of what
I was going to ask about.
Because I feel like it doesn't
get underlined enough that you
can have a
conversation, as opposed
to immediately going
to battle every time
you feel that maybe
it wasn't appropriate.
But on a larger
scale, I wanted to ask
you do you feel at all
concerned about this sort
of current surge of this--
being more attentive
to and sensitive?
Are you worried at
all that it will
create sort of this
new party line,
and it will actually
prevent some people
from critically thinking
about these issues?
Because there will
be things they're
literally not allowing
them to think about at all.
And I'm mainly referring
to, for example,
a couple of months ago
in "The Nation" there
was this controversy
with a poem that
was published by white poets.
And it was mimicking
about a homeless person,
mimicking a way that some people
thought [INAUDIBLE] to speak.
And then it was
disavowed immediately
by the editorial board
who published it.
So are you worried at all
about this actually stifling
conversation out of fear?
LUVVIE AJAYI: No.
Because if the idea
of being challenged
stops you from speaking, I think
you're taking the easy way out.
I know now, especially now
people are, like, oh, my God.
Everybody is now being so PC.
We're afraid to say anything.
No.
What's actually happening
is people are now, probably
for the first time ever,
being, like, you know,
people who are poor,
black, gay, trans,
they deserve to be treated
like whole human beings, which
means the old jokes and
the old do whatever,
say whatever won't fly.
If people are, like, well,
now I can't make jokes.
Now comedy is dead.
If comedy, and if
content, has always
been based in the
oppression of other people,
then it's been trash
for centuries, right?
So right now we're
at a place where
we're all being challenged
to be better than we've been.
It means, maybe don't make
the joke about ha, ha,
ha, boobs in the office
when before it was fine.
It could fly, right?
So now men are,
like, oh, my God.
I can't even make
jokes about boobs.
No!
There are other jokes to make.
What is this?
I think this is where I
think the conversations
on safe spaces are important.
Because you have to
have a place where
you can go to speak
freely, be given
grace, and not necessarily,
like, hung out to dry,
like Ned Stark for it.
I think there need to be people
you trust in your life, who
you can go to.
I think everyone needs to have a
personal board of directors who
are the people who
will challenge you
in your moments of failure, who
will pump you up in the moments
when you need it.
And I always, whenever
I make mistakes,
I go to my board of directors.
And they'll be, like, yeah.
You did misstep there.
And I'll be, like, OK.
If you said that
to me, and you're
someone who loves
me, who's smart,
who's thoughtful about the
world, I will believe that.
This doesn't mean you take
on every troll on Twitter.
Because no.
In fact, take on zero
trolls on Twitter.
But also listen to the actual
constructive criticism.
So a poem where a
white man is attempting
to speak like
somebody who he has
no idea what their life's
really like, it's punching down.
That's a rule, right?
The rule essentially
is don't punch down,
which is you shouldn't
make fun of people
who are more marginalized
than you, essentially.
Which is why black folks can
make fun of white people,
because we're punching up.
But the inverse is not
allowed, same thing.
I can't make fun of
somebody who is trans.
But they can absolutely
make fun of me.
I can't make fun of them
for their trans identity.
I can make fun of
other things, right?
Because maybe they're
Scientologists.
[LAUGHTER]
But I'm terrible.
I'm working on it.
But the concept is always
punch up, not punch down.
Which means if you're going to
talk about somebody's identity
and use it in a
point of a joke, it
can't be a point
of identity that is
more marginalized than yours.
So I can't make fun--
I'm Christian-- I can't
make a joke about somebody's
Muslim identity.
I am straight.
I can't make a joke about
somebody's gay identity.
You know what I mean?
So you have to kind of
operate in that way.
So a white man who is well off
writing a poem that essentially
is making fun of somebody who's
homeless is punching down.
AUDIENCE: Well.
He wasn't making fun of that.
That's my-- I mean, obviously,
I didn't [INAUDIBLE]..
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yeah.
But essentially think
about it, right?
We're also in a
moment where we're
seeing fashion-- for example,
in the US in the last month,
three major brands
have been in hot fire
because they created
products that
look like blackface,
which historically
has denigrated black people.
So in that moment, you
can be, like, well,
it's just this thing with red
lips that happens to be black.
What if it's just fashion?
Are we stifling the
creativity now because
of political correctness?
No.
It takes historical
context into effect.
So I think it's just
an interesting time.
There's going to be a lot of
mistakes being made, right,
across the board.
People are going to
make poor choices.
But we have to then fix it.
When we call them
in or call them out,
the point is that,
the hope is they
don't make the mistake again.
They see where the error is.
And in that moment when
you are challenged,
you don't instantly go
to I'm being trolled.
Right?
You also go to, OK, what
have I done here that I
can make sure I don't do again?
And how can I be an
example of what it
looks like to redeem yourself?
So it's an interesting time.
Again, I just talk about
speaking up in these moments.
I'm somebody who's
considered a truth teller.
But I also make mistakes, right?
And my mistakes are
also loud mistakes,
because I have such
a giant platform.
So if I'm ever afraid of
making too many mistakes,
and I make that stop
me from speaking up,
essentially what am I losing?
I can't be so afraid of making
mistakes that I shut up.
I just have to be willing
to make mistakes and then
grow from them.
And that is ultimately
what we can all do.
If you're willing
to make mistakes,
you're willing to be more risky.
And then when you make those
mistakes, try to grow from it.
Try to learn from it and
try to figure out how to not
make the same mistake again.
NOEILA FENANDEZ
ARROYO: That's awesome.
Thanks so much.
[APPLAUSE]
LUVVIE AJAYI: Thank
you for having me.
NOEILA FENANDEZ ARROYO: Oh,
it was a great, great time.